Python is special. It's used by the big tech companies, of course, but it's also used by
those you would rarely classify as developers. On this episode, we get a look inside how Python
is being used at a children's hospital to speed and improve patient care. We have Dr. Somac Roy
here to share how he's using Python in his day to day job to help kids get well a little bit faster.
This is Talk Python to Me, episode 470, recorded June 23rd, 2024.
Welcome to Talk Python to Me, a weekly podcast on Python. This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Mastodon, where I'm @mkennedy, and follow the podcast using @talkpython,
both on mastodon.org. Keep up with the show and listen to over seven years of past episodes at
talkpython.fm. We've started streaming most of our episodes live on YouTube. Subscribe to our
YouTube channel over at talkpython.fm/youtube to get notified about upcoming shows and be part of
that episode. This episode is brought to you by Sentry. Don't let those errors go unnoticed.
Use Sentry like we do here at Talk Python. Sign up at talkpython.fm/sentry. And it's brought to you
by Posit Connect from the makers of Shiny. Publish, share and deploy all of your data projects that
you're creating using Python. Streamlit, Dash, Shiny, Bokeh, FastAPI, Flask, Quarto, Reports,
Dashboards and APIs. Posit Connect supports all of them. Try Posit Connect for free by going to
talkpython.fm/posit. P-O-S-I-T. So, Mac, welcome to Talk Python. Awesome to have you here.
Hey, thank you, Michael, for the introduction. I'm happy to be here. Excited.
Yeah, I'm pretty excited to be talking about medicine and all the stuff that you guys are
doing with Python. And I really like these kinds of shows because I think it's important to
highlight that Python is not just for web developers and pure data science machine learning
people, but it's used by this huge spectrum of people doing all sorts of interesting stuff and
solving real problems with it. Right. And it sounds like you fall pretty solidly in that category.
Yeah, absolutely. It was like, you know, Python has been sort of this discovery as I've gone
through my career as a physician. And it's interesting how to begin with, when computer
science, initially when I was training and growing up, it was hard to imagine medicine and computer
science sort of being hand in hand together. But now I think things have progressed and there's a
lot of technology that's now in medicine that allows you to do all kinds of things. And of
course, as I've discovered Python, it brings in kind of the toolkit and the ability to be able to
achieve and solve problems in a way that I think it's not been envisioned before. So it's a very
exciting time. Yeah, it is a very exciting time. And I think it's just getting better and better.
Before we get too far into this, tell people a quick bit about yourself, quick introduction.
Yeah, absolutely. So I'm Somak Roy. I am a molecular pathologist. It's a type of physician
who deals with looking at the genome of either a patient or patient's tissue. And we essentially
look at all of these things in a way to be able to help manage patient's treatment. In my current
position, I am an associate professor and the director of molecular pathology at Cincinnati
Children's Hospital. My lab is a clinical lab that is under the division of pathology. And
we do a lot of work that pertains to kids in terms of helping them diagnose and manage
pediatric cancer, as well as infectious disease that happen in this age group.
Molecular pathology, I essentially trained back in India as a physician, did my MD,
and then came here, started in Pittsburgh, did my training in
pathology and lab medicine. I specialized in molecular pathology. Then I was there in
Pittsburgh. I worked for some time and then opened Cincinnati Children's.
Excellent. Do you work directly with patients or do you get samples sent to you from other
doctors and then you process them and analyze them?
Yeah, that's a good question. So I do not work with patients directly. It's a kind of,
it's a subspecialty in medicine where my lab works with the samples that have been collected
in the patient either from the OR or a procedure or from the radiology suite. And then we work on
that tissue or the blood sample or a bone marrow sample that comes to us. And yes, then all the
testing that we perform is off from that specimen. And then once we generate the clinical reports
back, they go back to the patient's chart and to the patients, to the clinicians who are treating
and managing them. And then that way it helps how they're able to then get a diagnosis and then
give the appropriate treatment and the management to the patient.
Yeah, excellent. So yeah, you must see a lot of different stuff flying through the lab you have
to analyze. So how did you go from, I'm studying medicine to I'm writing Python code and running
automation and what was that process like? Well, that was an interesting journey for me.
So before medicine and biology came into my life, I started off, it was second grade, I believe,
when my dad, he got me a computer at that time, which is a 64 kilobyte small machine.
I think it was for Toshiba MSX computers where you could write GW basic code and
some basic predefined hex code and you can run small applications on that. That was my starting
point. It was super exciting for me. And I think from there on, the journey went to, as I went
through high school and then college, medicine was, I would say, biology was something that
intrigued me. And at the same time, I also got interested in genetics, looking at DNA sequences.
And I had a natural liking for the fact that I could study about the cell or the genome, the DNA
and RNA. But also I realized that there was a lot of math and computation that you can use to slice
and dice data. And at that time, the place that I grew in India was a very small place. So we didn't
have access to resources like internet. So my exposure to internet was when I actually went to
med school for the first time. Oh yeah, you can actually connect to other computers. So that's
when I started my medicine. So obviously I did my training in medicine in medical school back in
India. That's when I started to connect and talk to a lot of people. And some of my friends who
actually were already writing apps at that time using Java applets and on browser. And so I started
to make some connection in terms of images and learning how some of those things can be used in
medicine. And so radiology, during my radiology rotation, that was my first real life, that was
my realization that actually in medicine, you can use computers a lot to handle a lot of these
and images, x-rays, CT scans. And I think as it went on, when I came to the US, that's where
it really started off. During my residency in pathology here, I actually connected with my
mentors, Dr. Anil Parwani and Dr. Leonard Pentamax. They are well-known pathology informaticists.
They've spent a lot of their time sort of dwelling in the world of pathology, medicine, and
computer science. And so that is when I could actually realize that, yes, you can do a lot of
innovative stuff by developing apps, algorithms, analyzing either image data or molecular data.
And so that is when I started to get into designing an app, which was a very simple web app that was
a project I was working with one of my mentors. And so his idea was that we had a lot of these
pathology images and we wanted to create a little in-browser app that would display these images as
thumbnails and then clicking the art that could enlarge the image, show that on display.
And so I used, at that time, it was .NET framework to be ASP.NET. And so I created a little app using
Visual Basic. Slowly I then migrated to using C# in the same environment. And that time,
I started my advanced fellowship training in molecular pathology. That's when I started there.
That's when I realized there's a lot of genomic sequencing data where essentially you're dealing
with a lot of strings and numbers. And you have to make a lot of sense in terms of this large
volume of data that comes in. - If we're working with, so the kind of data that you're working with
for say this genetic stuff. - Yes. - For us, for when you're studying the genomics, so how much
data is in say one strand of DNA? How much of that do you actually care about? Like, give me,
give us a sense of sort of how much data we're talking. - Right. So it really depends on what
has been done. And so when we look at, so when we talk about genomics, it is really designed on how
the experiment is done. So for example, if we just simply look at the entire human genome, we are
talking about 3 billion alphabets. Essentially it's the combination of four alphabets, A, T, G,
and C. So these are the four nucleotides of the DNA sequence. And the RNA has one additional one
which replaces A. But the idea is that it's a mix and match of these sequences. And so if you think
about the entire human genome as a single thread of A, T, G, and Cs in various combinations,
you're looking at 3 billion alphabets. And so what happens is when we do these sequencing
experiments where you would take the DNA molecule from a bunch of cells within a tissue, and then
either we read all the 3 billion base pairs. And typically the way the sequencing is done is you
read all of these sequences from many molecules. And so you'll have multiple copies of that when
you're translating from a molecular, like a chemical molecular structure to a DNA sequence
on say a plat file in a file system. So if you look at that large scale of data, like the entire
genome, we are talking of hundreds of gigabytes, maybe even terabyte worth of data. Then there are
other more practical approaches when we look at the genome. And especially this is something that
we use for day-to-day patient care, which is referred to as targeted sequencing. What that
means is instead of the 3 billion base pairs, we focus on those regions of the human genome
that are of most pertinent use, or that we at least as a current field of genomics, that we
understand what to do with. And so there are certain genes that at least in the space I work
with, cancer genomics, that are, I would say close to about maybe a thousand to 2,000 genes,
which are known to be cancer associated. And of that, roughly about five to 700 genes are where
we know that they have been studied and demonstrated that there are certain types of
abnormalities in those genes in terms of the sequence changes, that they have certain meaning
in context of tumor in order to make a diagnosis or to understand if the tumor is aggressive or
benign, or if there are certain treatments that could be applied to those tumors. And that's
specifically linked to the kind of sequence change you see in that region of the genome.
And we are talking about, practically speaking, when we talk about the targeted testing that we
do, it's a very small fraction of the large genome. Typically there's a term known as exome
sequencing, and exome sequencing refers to sequencing all those regions of the human genome
where it at least encodes for one or the other anodic gene. That is typically about one to 2%
of the entire genome. And so if we further narrow it down to about say five, 600 genes,
that one would typically sequence for practical cancer molecular testing. I would say that's
probably about a tenth, or maybe slightly less than that, of the genome, but it's a very high
yield from a clinical standpoint, because the most alteration you will find that would help
with the clinical treatment is high. So if we're going to talk about that dataset, it's complex in
a different way because just looking at the raw sequence data would be somewhere in, I would say,
one to 20 gigs from a single sequence file, but it entirely depends on how deep we go.
So for example, when we talk about sequencing, as I mentioned before, when we sequence a molecule,
we can sequence it either at certain depths, that means what level of redundancy you want
to be able to read that molecule. Sometimes we read the molecules 20 to 30 times, so that's
referred to as 30x, or sometimes we'll read that 500 times, so that will be 500x.
>> You do that because you want to make sure you don't misread the gene?
>> Yes. So, right. So what happens is the greater the depth of sequence, so typically for
such large panels that we sequence in a clinical setting, we usually target about 1500x to 2000x,
that means we're reading that 2000 times. So the more the depth it is, the possibility of identifying
a certain variation or genomic alteration that is present at a very low level. For example, say,
you have a tumor cell and within that, only 2% of the cells have this mutation, others don't.
And so when you're looking for or hunting for these needles in a haystack, you really want to
maximize the amount of depth you have to be able to pick those things up. So it really depends on
how deep we go. The more deep we go, the more data it is, and so it can scale up to almost
several hundred gigabytes. >> Sure. Yeah, I've always
wondered about how you can go and read somebody's genetics and then not make a mistake when you're
using chemicals to read. So, but it's really ridiculous how much data is there.
Off by one, a C for a G or whatever is a bad thing, right?
>> Right. But it is, I think as the technology has matured, there's not a hundred percent in terms
of the error profile for the enzyme that has been used to work, the technology that is reading the
actual fluorescence converting that to signal. There's always statistical values and probabilities
that are associated with what is the probability that it is wrong or incorrect or correct.
But within that frame and where the current technology is, it's pretty accurate for,
if not all, many of the regions of the genome. And so it's mind-baffling how it works.
>> Yeah, it really is quite amazing. It's one of the modern marvels of science for sure.
>> It is, it is. >> This portion of Talk Python
to Me is brought to you by Sentry. Code breaks, it's a fact of life. With Sentry, you can fix it
faster. As I've told you all before, we use Sentry on many of our apps and APIs here at Talk Python.
I recently used Sentry to help me track down one of the weirdest bugs I've run into in a long time.
Here's what happened. When signing up for our mailing list, it would crash under a non-common
execution path, like situations where someone was already subscribed or entered an invalid email
address or something like this. The bizarre part was that our logging of that unusual condition
itself was crashing. How is it possible for her log to crash? It's basically a glorified
print statement. Well, Sentry to the rescue. I'm looking at the crash report right now,
and I see way more information than you would expect to find in any log statement. And because
it's production, debuggers are out of the question. I see the trace back, of course,
but also the browser version, client OS, server OS, server OS version, whether it's production
or Q&A, the email and name of the person signing up, that's the person who actually experienced
the crash, dictionaries of data on the call stack, and so much more. What was the problem?
I initialized the logger with the string info for the level rather than the enumeration dot info,
which was an integer-based enum. So the logging statement would crash, saying that I could not
use less than or equal to between strings and ints. Crazy town. But with Sentry, I captured it,
fixed it, and I even helped the user who experienced that crash. Don't fly blind. Fix
code faster with Sentry. Create your Sentry account now at talkpython.fm/sentry. And if you
sign up with the code TALKPYTHON, all capital, no spaces, it's good for two free months of Sentry's
business plan, which will give you up to 20 times as many monthly events as well as other features.
So I think you're a little bit unusual, a little bit weird in the sense that you got in as your
first sort of programming thing to bring to apply to your science and medicine side of things was
C# rather than, or VB.NET, rather than something like Python or R or something. So maybe talk a
bit about that experience, contrast it with Python. Why do you end up moving to Python?
Yeah. So I think the reason I started using VB.NET C# was I would say most,
it was probably influenced a lot by at the time when I was doing my med school in India. What
was available at that time, it was not something I would just go to the internet and start getting a
lot of resources as one would do now. So it was pretty much like, this is the book I have available
and that's the only thing. So you start. But the thing is when I started applying C# and it was
mostly C# and a little bit of C++ and I started to get into like with some of the non-genetic stuff
initially, well, the project I'm working on, it was not too bad because I was able to accomplish
most of the tasks. But then once I got into genomics and I came, so the way professionals
who get into genomics and molecular pathology, there are a couple of different routes. So
either the physician, people who are physician trained and they have a formal background in
medicine and they do a specialized training and then they become molecular pathologists
after getting board certified. There is the other route, which is more of a research background,
where people have spent a lot of their time in really deep research. They've learned a lot of
genomics hands-on, either from a computational background or from a more laboratory, like a
wet laboratory background. And so they've obviously done their PhDs and postdoc training and then
sort of come into the molecular pathology field. People starting there tend to have more of a
formal computational training. So they're getting, they usually get, obviously when you start with a
research lab, R, Python are sort of like the most common tools that are used for
any kind of data analysis and data visualization. Coming from more of a foreign medicine background,
and typically when we get training in clinical informatics or pathology informatics,
often it is very, I would not say corporate based, but very formal application development space.
So it's a lot of Windows based, .NET, C#, C++, that kind of thing.
Standard enterprise stack. Yeah. Java or .NET is a perfect choice. Yeah. Okay.
In bioinformatics, at least in genomics bioinformatics, the ecosystem of tools available,
it's a mishmash of everything. For anything which is very computationally intensive, like when you're
trying to align sequences to the human genome, those are very intensive tasks. And typically
it's a lot of C, C++, Java, that's involved in some of these very mainstream tools that are
available. More recently, I think we are seeing Rust coming into the picture as well. There's
some Volang applications. And then of course, Python and R are the predominant, I think,
tools as the programming language that are used to solve all of these problems.
So when I started my molecular pathology fellowship and I got into, now I had to do
this project that involved manipulating all the sequence data to a point where we would be able
to develop an application that would help, it's a web-based application that could help
for other pathologists and faculty to read that sequencing data and digest in a very way that's
easy for them to look at it rather than going to the Linux terminal and opening up raw files and
things like that. So I used, that was my first project was to use C# in that context. But I
quickly realized that there was a lot of these algorithms that were natively either written in
R or Python and then having to incorporate those functionalities was not as easily possible.
So I had to rewrite a lot of those things in C#, Python primarily. It was a good learning curve,
but I think from a main derivative perspective, it was getting really difficult. And so that's
when we realized it was that I think a combination of Linux and Python was, I had to move towards.
Yeah. C# probably from the timeframe that you're thinking about, didn't really have a great package
manager story, not to the same degree that Python does. Although they do pretty good now over in
the continent land. Right. Yeah. All right. So a good question from Chris in the audience says,
is there a reason to use Python specifically? Like, are there some special sauce packages
that make it attractive? It sounds like that's kind of what you were getting at. Like you found
more solutions to these algorithms than, you know, available in Python than in C#.
Yeah. Whatever languages. Yeah.
Right. So I think, I mean, I think the simple answer is yes. I think the community and the
amount of work that has been done in this particular space with genomics, I mean, when you
are really searching for applications, it kind of falls into these three categories of, you know,
anything which is a high performance compiling program that is usually in the rust, C++, C,
a lot of those languages, a little bit of rust and Java. And then the other bin is essentially
kind of, you know, split up into Python and R. I think for me, Python was, and I think I'm sure
others have shared the same way where it's almost like, wow, this is amazing. Like coming from C#,
it was a little bit of a change because there's no more, like, you know, curly braces.
Think about the whole things. But I think the job
You don't miss your semicolons.
Kind of. Like even now, sometimes when I write like a little bit of JavaScript,
I feel like, oh, yeah, okay, this semicolon is here.
Exactly.
The curly braces. But, you know, not too bad. I think what I got onto was like the simplicity
of the language and how powerful it was when, like, if I'm thinking about, you know, it was
interesting when I had to do something like there was an algorithm where I had to parse out certain,
you know, strings in a way where it required some known workflows that we used to do, like,
variant annotations when we're cross referencing databases and putting them together. You know,
when you look for in terms of C# packages, there's really nothing there for it natively to do it. So
you have to write a lot of those things. In Python, the amount of time that is spent
in developing those things is much faster. Like the development time itself is quick because
you either get an idea of somebody who's already done the work or there's a more
formal package that you can use. So I think initially when I started off,
BioPython was a very interesting collection of packages. It was like a tool suite essentially
written to, you know, to have all these functions available for very common day to day tasks.
You know, I want to query a certain region of the BAM file or I want to parse out certain things in
the FASTQ file to look at some of the sequences or doing, you know, counting number of sequences
in a given file and, you know, getting read counts, things like that was, it's all out of
the box. And so that was sort of like the first thing to go, "Wow, this is amazing." I mean,
somebody's already done the work and we're just using it on top of it.
Yeah. Instead of creating these, I'll just like use those. Perfect.
Right. So that was one. And the other motivation to use Python was, you know, say for example,
why not R? Why Python? Because R offers a very rich ecosystem in, you know, at least in genomics
and visualization. So I think the second thing was in terms of the idea that I was working on was
having to develop a web application and all of these bioinformatics, you know, toolings and
algorithms running sort of in the back. And so at that time it was like, okay, well, you know,
Python, I've not heard much about in terms of web application. Mostly it was, you know, again,
this big, like, you know, C#.net. That was why I started off, you know, with that. But then at that
time, you know, there was Django and then Flask was sort of coming in. It was a very minimalistic,
you know, sort of application. So I started focusing on that. It was very easy with Flask to,
you know, get up and running with very simple, you know, applications to do that. I didn't try
much into Django just because it was too bloated for me. But, you know, Flask was great. And then
what I realized was you can create a simple web application, but then at the same time,
you can use all your, you know, my pythons and all the wonderful bioinformatics packages in the
backend. So it's like a single language that lets you do both. And so this is great. It was just,
I don't have to go anywhere to learn, you know, a third or a fourth or fifth different programming
language. And this just gets the job done. Yeah. Keep it in mind that your actually main,
your main job is medicine, not programming, right? It's not a CS person. It's just all after
out to learn all the languages, right? Right, right, right. So that definitely is,
again, that's a huge, you know, I would say I'm, again, as I said, I'm in a, I'm sort of
in an unusual position where I'm, you know, a physician, but I also do a lot of these
application developments. So that certainly is an important point in terms of how much time I have
to be able to develop these prototypes. And then obviously, you know, typically the way it works is
at least right now here, you know, where I am currently working, I have an excellent and amazing
team of developers and bioinformations who really do a lot of the development work on the front end,
back end. And so for me to be able to take additional time out of my, you know, the clinical
and the patient care work is limited. So if I can get whatever prototype I'm thinking of,
we're developing the application fast, then, you know, that's, that's what I'm going for.
And so you can hand it off to the team and let them polish it up and product,
make it production ready, basically. Yeah. Yeah. I was wondering how much time of your,
your job do you get to spend on these kinds of things, you know, finding new packages,
optimizing or improving the ways that you're working on stuff versus just sort of handing
it off to the folks you work with and, and keeping, you know, focus more on the medicine side.
Yeah. So it you know, that, that I think it's a good question. I think it's, it's evolved over
time as I've been, you know, being sort of, you know, when I was in training and then being a
faculty and then, you know, faculty in this new position you know, one of the things I did was
as part of my certification was to, you know, to get board certified in clinical informatics.
That's a discipline by itself that, you know, involves a lot of, you know, it's a very broad
field in terms of informatics and healthcare. And then one of the buckets there is, you know,
software development. And so I was you know, I was quite interested sort of in that field. And so
most of my time in terms of being able to devote to, you know, finding new packages or trying to,
you know, write up an application that could solve a problem or coming up with prototypes.
It was done in a way that sort of aligned with the work I was doing. And so it would be days
when I'm on clinical service where I'm mostly, you know, working on sort of with, you know, with
patient care related matters. So those weeks would be, you know, obviously very busy. I would have,
you know, I would wake up at like extremely early in the morning, spend the first two hours,
four to six a.m. just, you know, working on this. And then I get back to like, you know,
the clinical work. And then there would be weeks when I'm off clinical service. So I,
you know, I'm not responsible for any patient care related work. And those weeks would be
where I would spend time in terms of, you know, doing these, you know, investigating into sort
of some of these packages and, you know, coming up with new ideas, exploring what is all, you know,
what is available in terms of certain problems that I was solving. And, you know, that time
sort of, you know, my quote, protected time professionally was spent in that. And so that
would be, you know, maybe a week spent into like, hey, we are trying to look into this
variant annotation pool. And then we want to, you know, write wrappers around it. So it becomes
easy for, you know, our labs operation to be able to use that. And so, so kind of that,
that's how it works. So some of those either early mornings or, you know, the weeks I'm off
clinical services and how, how that works. This portion of talk Python to me is brought to you
by Posit, the makers of Shiny, formerly RStudio, and especially Shiny for Python.
Let me ask you a question. Are you building awesome things? Of course you are. You're a
developer or data scientist. That's what we do. And you should check out Posit Connect. Posit
Connect is a way for you to publish, share and deploy all the data products that you're building
using Python. People ask me the same question all the time, Michael, I have some cool data science
project or notebook that I built. How do I share it with my users, stakeholders, teammates, I need
to learn FastAPI or flask or maybe view or react.js Hold on now. Those are cool technologies,
and I'm sure you'd benefit from them, but maybe stay focused on the data project. Let Posit Connect
handle that side of things. With Posit Connect, you can rapidly and securely deploy the things
you build in Python, Streamlit, Dash, Shiny, Bokeh, FastAPI, Flask, Quarto, Ports, Dashboards,
and APIs. Posit Connect supports all of them. And Posit Connect comes with all the bells and
whistles to satisfy IT and other enterprise requirements. Make deployment the easiest step
in your workflow with Posit Connect. For a limited time, you can try Posit Connect for free for three
months by going to talkpython.fm/posit. That's talkpython.fm/POSIT. The link is in your podcast
player show notes. Thank you to the team at Posit for supporting Talk Python.
Is it changing fast? So I'll give you an analogy that you could tell me about your space. So
on one hand, in Python web world, you mentioned Flask and Django. Flask and Django, while they
are evolving, they're kind of the way they have been and they're pretty stable. And if you learned
Flask five years ago, you're still good to use Flask today. Or is it more like FastAPI, Pydantic,
msgspec? There's something new all the time that you got to keep learning to bring in. Are
there a ton of new packages just coming online or is there a set of really solid ones?
So I think it's both yes and no. And so it depends on what area we're working on. So right now in the
clinical lab that I'm directing here, when I came here in 2020, it was when we started off from
scratch. So essentially, the idea was to be able to bring up a pediatric cancer sequencing
infrastructure that was not available. And so it was ground up from the lab to personnel to space
to competition and such. And so we kind of have these sort of two big bubbles in that operation
from an informatics perspective. One of them is we essentially are in the process of developing
our custom lab information system. That's essentially a web app. And so we have that
space and the other space is bioinformatics. And so bioinformatics is a lot of the custom
scripting or the applications we develop is Python based. Some of them we do with Golang
when we need a little bit of performance aspect. And then the other aspect is the web app.
So from a web app perspective, when I started here, we actually started, we use FastAPI and
Python. So that's kind of, that was, so the idea was that, well, since you're starting from scratch
and I came to know about FastAPI at that point of time, the whole thing was about
a single way that was, I was pretty much sold on that aspect. And then, I think the whole tool
segment a lot of sense. I'm like, okay, well, this is perfect. I'm to be able to, I think when
I started FastAPI was, all about five or six. And so now obviously you can see a lot of change
happening there. So yeah, that definitely is a lot of fast pace. And so we kind of do catching
up in a sense where it has to be done in a careful way. The reason is because from, as compared to
more traditional research lab testing where at the end really, there's a lot of discovery,
there's a lot of excitement at the end, it all translates into being sort of, the data is
presented at a conference or you publish that as a manuscript and that's the end point. So if you
move off from version one to version three of an algorithm, you have to obviously make sure that
your research, everything is reproducible, but beyond that is not a problem. But when we're
talking about the same thing in context of a clinical care for a patient, the room for error
is very, very little. You can't make mistakes. And so the entire space of clinical testing is
very regulated in that sense, because there's a lot of requirement that you have to perform that
any change that's happened in your pipeline, say you're using some version of an application,
now you upgrade to a newer version. You have to demonstrate that the analytical performance in
terms of sensitivity and specificity for that pipeline didn't change. And so a lot of work is
needed when you go do a version upgrade. So we keep those things very controlled and careful
versus some other things which are more in the R&D space. There's a little bit more room to
play around with tools. Right. Yeah. Chris was asking an audience a great question about
basically, is it more exploratory? You just move really fast and don't really worry about
tests and stuff like that. It sounds like this is more of a production type thing. Like if it,
you're going to run it over and over. And if it gives a different answer at some point for
testing for a disease or something, that's really bad. You need it to be right all the time. And so.
Yes. So the room when we do new test developments or we bring a new algorithm, obviously that
part of which we refer to, there's a form of term that we use in lab medicines called
familiarization and optimization or O&F phase. That's where, you know, there's a lot of flexibility,
new tools, new version, trying out different things. But once it moves from that into the
validation phase, and then once we deploy the application, once the deployment is there,
it's a production application. We don't touch it unless something really has to be tinkered with,
or there's a bug that we have to fix. Who's in charge of running those apps? Is that people
on your team and your lab or is that the hospital or how? Yeah. So the way to set up here is,
so when I started off, I was the end of one. So I started off with the FastAPI application.
I had to build up the, we had a bioinformatics pipeline that I had initially authored. But
then when we went through the validation phase, I luckily had two people on staff who kind of
were handling the bioinformatics on the front end. And then eventually we had a third person who
joined the team. So then they were kind of helping me out with a lot of the actual groundwork of
writing the code, getting tests done, going through the validation data, summarizing that for me.
Being a lab director, it is my responsibility ultimately to sign off on all those things,
say, "Hey, okay, this is the validation and this is what is being demonstrated that
your package or your pipeline or whatever you're working on demonstrates this level
of sensibility." Then yes, I being a lab director say that, yes, this is working.
And once that happens, so we then deploy those applications in production. We use GitHub and
another, the usual dev, test, prod cycle. And so that's kind of how it works.
Well, do you have your own hardware or do you have stuff like on DigitalOcean or AWS?
So with healthcare data, there is generally a little bit of angst with data sitting on the cloud
outside the support institution. I would say the institution that I work on is very,
that way it's quite very forward thinking and being able to use modern technology.
So what we started off and since it was everything being built up from scratch,
we had taken the decision to keep things on-prem for beginning. But we also kept in mind that
at some point of time, if the institution decides that, "Oh, we're going to switch our
infrastructure to using AWS or Azure or whatever the platform is going to be," that we want it to
be ready. And so the way we had it set up, and this is due to our amazing IS team here at our
institution. So we had our own hardware that we got in terms of the actual servers. And we
collaborated with the IS team to be able to help us build our Kubernetes infrastructure.
So we have a test and a prod Kubernetes cluster, and then all our apps and the bioinformatics
pipeline. Well, the apps for now and the bioinformatics pipeline that we're looking
forward in the near future to get deployed on these things. As a matter of fact, what we've
done is our dev team, we start to, we do a lot of the development on Kubernetes as well. And then we
keep moving all these things as containerized applications.
That's excellent. So really embracing containers and Docker and Kubernetes, and that should make
it super easy to move to wherever you want to go, right? Anything that can run Kubernetes,
you just push to that and you're good to go.
Right. Right. I mean, it's a little bit difficult to start with, but I think once
we are in that stream, it is much less effort to move things around.
Yeah. Last year I rewrote all of our servers and APIs and condensed six to eight servers all into
one just Docker cluster. And it was a great decision, but to me, it was also a little
intimidating to like, well, here's one more thing I layer, I have to manage and understand. And if
something goes wrong there, then everything else still breaks. But having it set up is really nice
once you get used to it. All right. Let's talk a bit about, well, I have a question for you. I
want to talk about some of these packages that you've been saying are like a lot of the reasons
you chose Python and you use a lot, which is great. But before we get there, like I got the
biopython.org website pulled up. And the very first line is, "Biopython is a set of freely
available tools." You know, open source, freely available. How much does that matter to you guys?
On one hand, you have a ton of money being in the medical space. It's really high stakes. So
paying for commercial software or commercial libraries is probably not the biggest worry.
On the other hand, open source is really nice. Being able to look inside is really nice.
Free means you don't have to deal with getting permission. How does that fit into your world?
I know how it fits into like small startups and things like that, but for a hospital, for example,
what does free and open source mean to you guys? I think it does have a lot of impact in terms of
how we end up working and setting up these things. And obviously, whatever I'm speaking
is representing what it means from sort of an operational standpoint. When we talk about
molecular pathology, generally being able to bring up a clinical service like that is a huge investment.
And so a lot of the investment is... And this is generally applicable to any institution where
something like this has been set up for patient care or clinical use.
The investment is primarily in a lot of the instrumentation and the reagents that we use
are generally quite expensive, which is sort of the... I would say when we talk about what is the
cost of a test when it's offered, that cost factors in a lot of these operational costs
that we need to buy these expensive sequencing instruments, the reagents that are used as
consumable as we do the test over and over again, every week, every month.
So from that standpoint, traditionally, the way things have been designed is,
I would say 10 years back when we would work with our finance team to say, "Okay,
the cost of the test is going to be so and so based on all of these different inputs." And so
10 years back, computation, bioinformatics, all of these were not factored in at all.
But now as we are in that era where using GPUs on a regular basis to be able to do simple...
I would not say simple, but routine work to get from the raw sequence data to be able to identify
genomic variants, that's getting common. Using FPGAs, using large clusters to be able to perform
these tests. And so now we are starting to see those costs getting in as part of the ultimate
cost that goes to the patient for a test. And so we try to minimize those things.
One of the ways to be able to minimize those things is to be able to choose between
free open source versus something which is a commercial product. And it's always a balance
between the reliability and the service that you're able to get back saying, "Hey, something
breaks down. We know there's an SLA. There's a certain assurance that this thing is going to
have help," versus open source free would be where we feel very confident in the code base.
Sometimes what happens is when we use some of these open source tools, we end up almost
invariably having some wrapper around it to change things or being able to have some insight
into the source code. So it depends on that balance, what we choose.
How often do you fork it and use your self-maintained version versus just run what
is publicly on PyPI and then maybe wrap it to orchestrate it a bit?
So I would say for the web application part of it, we don't really do a lot of forking. We kind
of go with what it is. The only thing what we do is since we have the luxury of using a combination
of GitHub and containers and knowing the fact that the regulatory requirements require that
you tightly version control all these things with history and all those things, we tend to,
when we are developing these things, when we are validating it, before we do that, we try to stick
to a fairly stable version. So for example, things like beta or release candidates, we try to stay
away from that. Even if they have some desirable features, but unless we see a full production
version of that, we don't tend to switch to it. So we keep things like that without maintaining
or without forking or making modifications. When we get into more of the bioinformatics stuff,
where we are actually trying to use an algorithm to solve a particular piece of
part of the pipeline that is doing some data transformation, it depends on how much we want to
change or modify. That's when we sometimes fork it. Sometimes we fork where we know that,
and this is the unfortunate reality in many of the scenarios where you have great open source tool,
but after some time due to whatever financial or business or other reasons that they stop
maintaining. And so essentially we get into this freeze mode. We tend to fork that so that at least
we have that available. And then if we make any changes that we keep it to that fork.
But generally I would say it's probably in the 80, 20, where 20% is where we fork it,
make some change. Most of the times we try not to do that. But yes, open source,
free tools have a big impact. A lot of their tools that we use as part of our
bioinformatics pipelines, as a matter of fact, which is kind of used in the community of
molecular pathology to build these bioinformatics pipeline. They tend to use a lot of open source
tools. And the reason for that is, for example, it's not written in Python, but we have,
there's an algorithm called BWA. It's written by Professor Heng Li. That's one of the algorithms
that is almost like a de facto, I would say, when it comes to doing sequence alignment,
that's a part of the pipeline. And so it's a tried and tested application for more than a decade now.
So really there's not a, and this is a fairly stable algorithm or application. So we don't
tend to, it's well maintained from an open source perspective. So those obviously are highly,
we highly rely on those. But there is this whole ecosystem of softwares that come under this
rubric term of variant calling, where we're trying to identify these different variants.
There's a whole bunch of those and some are fairly well maintained. They are open source.
Sometimes depending on the context you're using, you need a license if it is used in a commercial
setting. You don't need a license if it is in an academic setting. Like for example,
when we do clinical testing in institutions such as where I am right now, that's an academic
institution. So typically it's not for profit. And so obviously we don't need licenses for that use.
But once this goes into a pure commercial space where if the lab is doing all of this testing
for profit, then there's a license requirement. So we see a combination of these things showing
up in the, it's actually becoming more common now with open source tools that, at least in the
genomic bioinformatics space. Yeah. Oh, excellent. I think another benefit probably for you guys,
I know it's a benefit for a lot of organizations is if you use the open source tools and you need
to hire somebody new, there's a good chance that they have experience already with those tools.
Whereas if you use something private, expensive, you might have to teach them from scratch what
the thing is, right? Yes, that is correct. As a matter of fact, it's fortunate that a lot of the
people who've done a lot of good work and have contributed to the genomics bioinformatics space
have, the general tendency is whenever we are setting up any sort of pipelines or DNA sequencing,
RNA sequencing, or more from a research perspective, methylation sequencing, single cell RNA-seq,
UMI-based error-corrected variant calling, there's a lot of, there's a very thriving open
source space. And so that really helps with people who come in, even if they're not familiar with
these tools, it's easy to get familiar with because there's a lot of community backing that up.
Or as you said, when we hire people who already are coming from a different lab or they've had
some experience, but they come and say, "Oh yeah, we know how to do alignment, or I'm aware of these
applications that use that." It is much, much easier from a learning curve perspective rather
than having to now open up a manual and this will be a proprietary thing that only works here.
Yes, exactly. Cool. All right. Well, we coordinated a bit on a list of packages that you've used in
your lab or find really helpful for your work. And maybe we could touch on those just a little bit.
Yeah.
Yeah. So CNV kit, genome-wide copy number from high throughput sequencing. I don't know what
that means, but tell us about it.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely. So CNV or copy number variation, this is a type of genomic operation
where what happens is in a simplistic way, at least when we talk about cancer, the cancer cells,
sometimes for it to be able to survive, it tries to use different ways of doing that biologically.
One of the way to do that is certain genes that help a cell to grow in the absence of nutrients
or with very little nutrition is certain genes. If it has more copies of those genes than normal,
then you'll go, "Oh, okay." It's like you have more money than expected, you can do a lot of
things. So typically what happens is in a normal human genome, any cell that we pick up, it will
only have two copies of the gene. One is coming from your mom, one is coming from your dad.
In cancer, what happens is in certain scenarios, if a gene that helps with growth of the cell or
it helps the cell to survive even without signal or nutrition, if it has more copies of that,
it'll make six, eight, 20, 50 copies, it can survive. Versus there are certain scenarios
where if there is a gene that is supposed to regulate the cells, so it doesn't go haywire,
if the cancer is able to delete one of the genes out, then you only have one gene left.
You knock out a thing and then that protective mechanism is gone. So then the cancer cell can
easily survive. So what happens is with CNV or copy number variations, the idea is that we use
the high throughput sequencing data to be able to infer how many copies of these genes do we have.
Is it more than two? Is it less than two? And so this particular package, it's a very, very
well-established, well-maintained package in the community that essentially does this thing.
Is you give it the sequencing data and define the regions of the genome that you're interested in.
You can also provide names for the regions, like this region is gene B-RAF or this is EGFR,
whatever you're interested in. And then what I do is I will do all the analysis to be able to
tell you that, okay, well, when we are comparing this particular tumor against this reference set
of 20 normal samples, where we know that you should only have two copies of the gene,
in this particular tumor, we are seeing there are 50 copies of the gene.
So it gives you an output data that numerical can tell you that what it does is it does a
log-2-based transformation of the tracing there. Okay. After all this computation,
when I compare to the normal, this is 50 times more, or this is 20 times more the
expected copy, or it is half of the amount of copy we need in terms of deletions.
So that's what really it does. And it's written in Python. It has Python dependencies that have
been written in either C or Python C bindings. But at the end, it gives you that data. And it
has an internal visualization tool, but I was not very happy with how it was written. So
I ended up writing a wrapper, which is called CNA plotter. It's open source. It essentially
uses the end data from CNBKid, and then it gives you a nice visualization of the copy numbers.
I think if you go down, if you scroll down, there's my example images.
- Yeah, you have this on GitHub, so if people want to use this, it's right there, right?
- Yep, it's right there. So I think at the very bottom of the images,
by the screenshots there.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yep, right here. So for example, the first image over here, you can see this,
it's a thin band of all these multicolor things, and each one of them is a single
human chromosome. So chromosome one, two, three, four, so on and so forth. And if you look at the
image, it is at, the white scale essentially is log two, which is zero. And going up,
it is one, two, three, and then it's a negative scale on the lower side. So anything going above
zero means you have more copies than two, going below is less than two copies. And so if you see
here in this example, the plot here, you see the very end, which is chromosome X, is a single,
the band over here is lower at negative one. That means this is a male patient with a single X
chromosome, as compared to females who have two X chromosomes. And so when you look at this plot
below here, this is actually a plot from a cell line, a tumor cell line that is abnormal. And
here we see there are two genes which are amplified. One of them is a gene known as TERT,
and the other gene is MDM2. So these two genes are, again, one of those examples where it gives
the tumor survival advantage over other. And so you can see here there are multiple copies of
these genes as compared to the baseline over here. - I see. So that might predict something like the
how survivable the cancer is. - Yes. Right. So if it is, is it going to be localized,
say, where it happened, or it's going to like spread to other parts of the body,
or be difficult to treat, or be resistant to treatment. Yes.
- So if this is you, you want higher numbers, not lower numbers.
- It all depends. I mean, certain genes are good genes, for example, if there is a,
there are certain checkpoint genes, if those numbers, you know, if they have lower numbers,
you want to have two copies of them, because if that protective mechanism is gone,
you know, the tumor becomes very aggressive. - I see.
- So it is all in the context. So if you're looking at the good genes, you want to have
two copies of the good gene. If you're looking at some of the bad genes, you don't want to have
more than two copies of the bad genes. - One or zero is better. I got it. I got it.
Okay. Okay. HGVS. - Yes. This is, again, a wonderful package
that was initially, I think it was started by a person named Vishat. He's, I think he still
maintains it, but there's a lot of like, you know, it's a very well publicly maintained
open source package. It's a lot of, you know, community involvement in that as well.
So what HGVS is, it's a nomenclature system for, you know, giving a name to all these variations.
So when you talk about, I'm not sure if Michael, if you've heard about the term mutation.
So mutation is a very commonly used term that refers to some kind of abnormality in the
genome. In this case, so what happens is there are these standards that are, that, you know,
most clinical labs follow when they're putting all of this information in the patient's report
saying, okay, you know, this particular tumor has, you know, mutation in beta, mutation in EGFR,
some other gene. And there's a certain way that those mutations are described in terms of what
sequence alterations happening, say at the mRNA level and what sequence alterations are happening
at the protein level. So now in your protein, you know, you're missing these amino acids or
you have excess of these amino acids or something got switched from here to there.
So there's a formal way of defining that. And the guidelines of the group that defines that is
referred to as HGVS, Human Genome Variation Society. And so it's a very complicated process
where you have to do all these translations from the, you know, the genomic scale where
the numbering system starts from one to like, and you know, whatever the length of your chromosome
is in terms of ATGCs and each chromosome has a different number. And if you have a certain
alteration that is happening, say in chromosome seven at this particular position, then you have
to translate that to the mRNA of that gene and then the protein of that gene. So it's a lot of
math, a lot of strings involved in that process. And so essentially this HGVS Python package
provides all of those functionality as a wrap. You can create your translation. You can essentially
project the variant from your genomic to the, you know, the mRNA to a protein level or vice versa.
You can validate things. So we ended up, I actually wrote a paper about this when we,
you know, we did a validation of how well this particular package works. And so now, you know,
in the lab that I'm currently in, we implement this thing for generating those nomenclatures.
So what happens is when we put a report out for the, in the patient's chart and when our, you know,
say our oncology, oncologist was treating the patient, they want to know, okay, what is,
you know, what did you identify in this tumor genome? They will read that nomenclature saying,
oh, okay, this particular change in this BF gene, this is significant. I know that there are
therapies that are out there that we can use to treat this patient tumor. So that's what this
nomenclature system is about. So it's a very complicated automated system.
Yeah. And it normalizes it if there's multiple ways to represent it.
Very, very nice. All right. This one I'm familiar with, OpenPyXL.
Yes.
You probably have a lot of data that either goes,
comes from or goes, it's shared out into Excel, right?
Yes. So what we do is we sort of are right now in our lab, we're kind of in this sort of,
you know, kind of an interim phase where we sometimes use Excel to look at some data. So
traditionally speaking before, you know, typically any lab that goes from, you know,
zero to the point where you have a web application that automates everything,
the intermediate phase is using a lot of Excel. So it's very common in many labs
to use Excel for a lot of different things, you know, for QC, for charts, for tracking. So
we use this OpenPyXL for a few things. One of them is when we have a lot of,
you know, the sequencing data that we have to summarize and then generate a QC to be able to
present that to essentially create an Excel document on the fly from the backend to provide
that, you know, whatever data they want to look at in terms of statistics or, you know,
list of variants or some form of, you know, calculation they want to do further. That's
where we use this package. Typically we use it as part of our bioinformatics pipeline when we
have to generate those things. But it's a very handy tool. We actually use something similar,
and I'm forgetting the name of the package that is used to generate our document. Like we use some
Word documents for creating reports, but we also use Python there to be able to summarize a lot of
these data points and then create a Word document that, you know, it starts with a template of a
Word document and then use Python to fill up all these, you know. Right. Here's where the graph
goes. Here's where the summary goes. Here's where the detected, whatever it goes. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
Cool. Are you, here's two things that overlap. Are you familiar with this thing where scientists
rename human genes to stop Excel from misreading? Oh yes. Yes, absolutely. Oh my gosh. This is
crazy. Yes. Yes. It happens. When we import a lot of this data coming from somewhere, we'll see
entries like September 14th or March 19th. Yeah. This is a big problem going in and out of Excel.
And so as much as you can do in Python or any proper programming language, rather than using
Excel, but there was one that was M-A-R-C-H one or March one. Yes. Or S-E-P-T one.
It's very funny. Some of the gene names are funny, but then Excel, you know, gets it to the next
level when it changes the names. This doesn't make any sense. Yeah. Yeah. It doesn't make any sense.
Yeah. All right. On to the next one. Hera. Yes. Hera. This is very interesting. So this is where
I think, you know, where in our instance, we are going away from standard web applications,
standard bioinformatics pipeline to really touching DevOps using Python. And so one of the things
that typically we get to the point when we scale up our bioinformatics pipeline, where we have
multiple samples and multiple runs and everything needs to be orchestrated in a way where you have,
you know, while you're running your pipeline, you have a lot of visibility into how it works.
And so this is one of our projects we're working on to move our current bioinformatics pipeline,
the way it works, you know, kind of on a single server to be able to use the Kubernetes cluster
to actually deploy the long running pipelines onto that. And so there are many options. You know,
there are a more standard sort of, you know, a little based, you know, kind of, you know,
protocols that you can use to run on either cloud or HPC environments. There is a very popular tool
called Nextflow that is used to be able to, you know, kind of create your data analysis pipeline.
We can sort of define that and then use any backend to deploy it. One of the things that we
kind of, when I was exploring the space, one of the things I came across was, you know, the whole
sort of ecosystem that Argo maintains with, you know, Argo workflow and Argo CI/CD and all those
things. So workflow was interesting because Argo provides that way where you can sort of, you know,
write your pipelines in a YAML format and then have it, you know, deployed on the Kubernetes
cluster. It really is very native to the Kubernetes cluster. It sounds a little bit like Ansible,
but for specifically for bio type of projects, right?
Yeah. So Argo, so interesting thing is Argo, when, you know, when this Argo workflows was set
up really for a lot of CI/CD automations in mind. So, you know, it is, yes, you can run data
pipelines in general, but never, it was never, at least in its description, it never describes
use case sort of in bioinformatics or, you know, biology pipeline analysis. And similarly,
you know, it was like, okay, it's a generic tool. You can use it for whatever you want.
So I tried it out with using, you know, like a YAML file and it was a simple four-step pipeline.
It was wonderful. It was magical. And the good thing was with Argo, like the Argo workflow,
when you install that on your Kubernetes cluster, it comes with a native web interface. So it's,
you know, I'm sure if you've heard about the workflow option with Airflow. So Airflow is a
package that also, you know, there's a nice Python SDK for that, where you have, you know,
you deploy it on a Kubernetes cluster. We have all these amazing visualizations to show what step
you're on, or if there's some error there, it'll do that. Argo does the same thing. So it has,
it has obviously the built-in capability to interact with it as an API, but then also there's
a web interface that it'll deploy and it can have visibility into every step of the process. You can
summarize and see the entire tree. So that was very interesting for us because we could get all
that thing done in a single thing, in a single go. But then our challenge was, well, our desire was
that if you could integrate that with our LIMP system that we were working on using FastAPI,
so the idea was, hey, if there's any Python SDK. And so that's where Hera comes. So Hera
essentially is a SDK, a wrapper that's essentially talking to Argo, but you can define your pipeline
steps as, you know, DAGs in Python. And so that makes the process super simple, where you're now
natively, essentially we can integrate that as a backend to our web application. And so then it's
almost like, you know, it's Python again, from start to finish, you're not getting out of that.
And it's, again, it's a very well-maintained application. So we are currently doing a
validation to be able to make sure that, or demonstrate that, you know, it's equally
performant when we compare to a more sort of native shell-based, you know, execution on the
pipeline. Okay. Yeah. This is new to me. I mean, of course I know Airflow, but not Hera. Cool.
All right. Hi, in Sim, did I grab the right one here?
No, I think it's similar. Let me see if I can, I can send you the link.
Yeah. Throw it in the private chat here and I'll pull it up.
Yeah. Okay.
Here we go. In Sim.
Yeah. Okay. Got it.
Yeah. So this is a, this is a very interesting space in next generation sequencing assay or for,
you know, high throughput sequencing assays. So what happens is, as I mentioned, that one of the
things that is required for a clinical lab is to be able to perform a validation on multiple samples
of tumors that have certain mutations. And then you can demonstrate that, you know, yes,
the assay works because you have tested, you know, a hundred samples that have 300 different,
you know, mutations or genetic alterations. And then you can demonstrate that, yes,
your pipeline or your assay was able to pick it up. So you can say that, you know, your assay is,
you know, X percentage sensitive, X percentage specific, and you know, your
recall rate and things like that. So what happens is when you're trying to
get those samples that have these very difficult or challenging variants to detect, because
they're just, you know, complex in how they occur biologically in the cell, it's very difficult.
Some of these are very rare. There may be only two samples in the entire world. Or it's just
not possible practically to get those samples unless we wait for like, you know, 10 years to
validate that. So the idea is that if it is possible to be able to use algorithms, which can
manipulate the existing sequence. So for example, we have a sequence data from an existing real
tumor sample, but we can manipulate that in a way where we introduce these mutations in silico.
So we can introduce, you know, SNBs or insertion, deletion mutations, and then
use that same file to then feed into our pipeline, bioinformatics pipeline and say,
okay, run through the entire data pipeline. And then let's see if we are able to identify
those variants that we inserted. And so that's where this silico mutagenesis comes.
It's a very hot topic. It's a very relevant topic of interest to really fill this large
gap in terms of availability of rare variants and their samples and how we can really improve
sort of some of these rare, but very clinically significant edge cases where we don't want to
miss those variants and actually see those in real tumor samples. And so this is a Python package
that was developed by at the University of Chicago as part of their clinical lab. And so what really
it does is it will take in a list of different, you know, mutations, for example, in this plot,
I think they give examples of, you know, insertion, deletion, insertions, where you have extra
sequence or deletion where you have certain signals which are missing or SNVs or single
nucleotide variants where you have one nucleotide that got switched with another one. And so these
are typically that we practically see in like real samples or real tumor samples, but this is a way
to mimic that, you know, in a sample that does not have it. And so this Python package is able to,
you know, take that list from you say, okay, I have a list of these 20 important mutations that
I know from the public databases have been reported, but I want them to be inserted into
my dataset that was created from say, a set of three or four real tumors, and then use that to
challenge the pipeline to say that, hey, can you still pick it up? And so I see.
I see. Simulate these rare changes and then test or exercise your setup.
Yeah, right.
We've got a few more to cover, but I think we're getting a little bit short on time. So let me just
close this out with a final question for you, because I know this is the topic du jour.
What does AI and LLMs look like for you guys? Does it matter? Is it really powerful? Is it
super important? I mean, genetics is kind of text data in a sense. And so,
yes, sort of in the space of how it could apply.
Right. It is a text data and it's a lot of, you know, there's a, when you talk about like a search
space, a lot of the search space is very text-based. You know, there is some numerical
base, but there's a lot of text-based search as well. And I think across the entire spectrum from
where we start with very raw sequencing data to the point that we are trying to,
you know, ask the question that, okay, I found this rare or novel mutation in this particular
gene. What does it mean? What tumor has been described? What disease does it relate to?
One of the things that we do as molecular pathologists, and this is sort of where a lot
of the medical work comes in, is where we really go through a lot of the medical literature,
what we have learned before, new publications, papers out there that, you know, that have a lot
of data in terms of, you know, studies that are done on this particular gene. And they've described
like, okay, these alterations actually activate the gene or is bad for the tumor or, you know,
makes it treatment resistant. So you can see the natural, there's a lot of text as it happens.
And so in that space, we are seeing in the, I would say in the past, you know, three to four
years, there's been a lot of application of AI tools that have come out, you know, particularly
in the space of variant calling, where we have this genomic sequence data and we're trying to
identify variants. You know, one of the examples that's been talked about a lot is the
deep variant caller. It's called deep variant from the team at Google who developed that.
That uses a lot of the AI techniques to be able to pick those things up.
There are some genomic databases that we use for in silico prediction. For example,
if you have a variant, we have no idea about it. It uses, there's a database called DB-SC-SNV that
uses random forest techniques. And I think it uses another algorithm to predict if a certain
site where there's a mutation can enhance abnormal mechanism called splicing versus not.
Similarly, there's a lot of tools that are coming in and the LLMs, I think are,
I would say not mainstream, but I think there's a lot of interesting research that is coming
around there, but people are trying to use LLMs for doing these more broader excerpts saying that,
hey, you know, I have these, you know, I don't know, a thousand articles, and I want to find
these particular combination of words that, you know, you know, it's a combination of a disease
and a mutation and what do I get back on that? I personally tried, you know, the ChatGPT with
different, you know, like phrases and questions about it. What I've seen so far is, and this is
purely my personal experience. I think a lot of it reads very real, but when you start to look
into the references as to what it references, then you quickly figure it out. This is not the
real deal. And so I think, I think it's, you know, I'm not a very pessimistic person. I would say,
oh no, this is all garbage, but I think there is opportunity there. It's just how do you train it.
Maybe there's a space or an opportunity, and it probably already has been,
people are pursuing this as training a smaller model, but really deeply in genetics,
whereas trying, not trying to use a model that tries to understand everything.
Right. Right. Yeah. It's more, yeah. More in the medical literature or the genomic literature
to be able to like, meaning is enhancement. Yes. So I think there's active work going on there,
but it's, yeah, it's, I think it's making, you know, a lot of, a lot of interesting
research, a lot of potential impact on how, you know, we do things. And obviously the tool sets
that we currently use, we might expect in the next 10 years to change.
Yeah, for sure. All right. Final thought here, people are listening. They're maybe doing similar
work to you. How do they get started? What would you tell them? Get going with Python and some of
these packages? Yeah. I mean, I would, you know, my reflecting on my own experience sort of, you
know, in a very winded way that I ended up here, I think, you know, Python is, I feel the program
in general, and I think Python particularly as a programming language is a very low, you know,
sort of, you know, entry point in terms of being able to really quickly get things done, like learn
it easily and get things done. I think it should be to me, anybody, anybody who's trying to pursue
something in biology or competition biology or bioinformatics, I think this is the first thing.
It's something easy to do to be, you know, I would say relatively easy to do, to be able to get in
that. Anybody with, you know, a desire to learn this has analytical thinking. I mean, I think
investing into Python is probably the best bet because you can pretty much do anything you want.
That's what I tell, you know, when I train people in my lab or I talk to other students, is that
if you want to spend your time, you have very little time because you're busy, you know, with
your other things. I think the one thing that can get some of the job done and be still aligned with
what you're doing is Python. And after that, I think it's, you know, it's a lot of self-driven
learning where, you know, you kind of, you know, look into things. But the whole thing is,
I think the Python community is wonderful. It's almost like I sit down and I think about, oh,
I have to solve this problem. Probably there are 50 other people who are thinking about that and
maybe two people have already worked on it. So it's-
Right, and you've already published it to PyPI and you're good to go.
Absolutely. I totally agree with that. And, you know, people should take the couple of weeks,
get good at it, and it'll amplify. It'll save you time, definitely, in the long run.
It is, yeah. Oh, absolutely. Yes. The only thing that I, that I, the only thing I would say,
like an added thing is if somebody is learning Python and then they do have an intention,
you know, to take it to the point where they will be involved in more serious,
like, you know, application development or maintaining an open source package or,
you know, however they contribute to that. I think learning a little bit more,
like learning Python in its real sense in terms of how to do it right. You know, there are five
ways of doing something correctly. But I think there's one way that is consistent so that it's,
again, you know, easily shared, it's easily maintainable, others can easily understand.
I think that would be my second advice. It is, it takes a little bit of time, but I think it's
well worth the effort to spend the time writing, you know, idiomatic Python code. So it's,
it's portable. Absolutely. All right. So, Mac, thank you for being on the show. It's been
great to get this look inside of what you all are doing with Python.
Yeah. Thank you for having me on the show. I appreciate that.
Yep. Bye.
Okay. Bye, bye.
This has been another episode of Talk Python to Me. Thank you to our sponsors. Be sure to check
out what they're offering. It really helps support the show. Take some stress out of your life.
Get notified immediately about errors and performance issues in your web or mobile
applications with Sentry. Just visit talkpython.fm/sentry and get started for free. And
be sure to use the promo code talkpython, all one word. This episode is sponsored by Posit Connect
from the makers of Shiny. Publish, share, and deploy all of your data projects that you're
creating using Python. Streamlit, Dash, Shiny, Bokeh, FastAPI, Flask, Quarto, Reports, Dashboards,
and APIs. Posit Connect supports all of them. Try Posit Connect for free by going to
talkpython.fm/posit. P-O-S-I-T.
Want to level up your Python? We have one of the largest catalogs of Python video courses over at
Talk Python. Our content ranges from true beginners to deeply advanced topics like memory and async.
And best of all, there's not a subscription in sight. Check it out for yourself at
training.talkpython.fm. Be sure to subscribe to the show, open your favorite podcast app,
and search for Python. We should be right at the top. You can also find the iTunes feed at
/iTunes, the Google Play feed at /play, and the Direct RSS feed at /rss on talkpython.fm.
We're live streaming most of our recordings these days. If you want to be part of the show and have
your comments featured on the air, be sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel at talkpython.fm/youtube.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy. Thanks so much for listening. I really appreciate it.
Now get out there and write some Python code.